the politics of hate is the business
model
of cable television it's the business
model of digital platforms
and it's incredibly profitable it just
happens to be
incredibly destructive for the capacity
of a democracy to do anything
um and yet that is reality that we see
in the way media operates it's the
reality around fundraising i mean the
fact is if you've got to raise money the
old-fashioned way
the most reliable technique you've got
is the politics of hate to sort of gin
up hatred to the other
side make it seem like they're the devil
if they have any power at all it'll be
the end of the republic
and that drives the passion to get money
into your side
and if we don't find a way to build
democracy on top of a platform that
doesn't depend
on making us stupid and hate each other
we're not going to build a democracy
and and and i agree it's really
important to recognize it's not just
campaign finance reform a finance i mean
that's
a symptom of a deeper problem but the
cable and the digital problem
is really profound and given the first
amendment there's relatively little the
government can do about it but we need
to think creatively about
how we're going to address that problem
too i have an idea
that i'm trying to develop around it
because it to me
so you have and so let's put uh
let's put people here and then media
corporate interests
sort of as a layer between um people and
legislators and we'll put legislators on
top and then legislators have their own
messed up incentives so to me the media
lair is vital
because right now we're turning on each
other we're more polarized than ever a
lot of people
are losing faith that we can get
anything done together
uh which is being borne out by the facts
you have congress walking away from
uh a recovery act uh even though it's
obvious to all of us that
we need to extend benefits and uh you
know so the polarization is going to
destroy us
and the media unfortunately benefits
from that polarization so what do you do
so here's my suggestion you're right
that uh we have first amendment
protections and no one necessarily wants
uh
folks to to be governing what can and
can't be said in various news outlets
on the other side you have over a
thousand local newspapers that have gone
out of
business because they can't survive uh
you know craigslist and internet ads
have
disrupted their their advertising models
and so
to me if you want a functioning
democracy you need to have local papers
and there have been studies that showed
that if you don't have
any local news source in your town then
you just vote
on very polarized lines and nothing ever
gets done is bad for democracy and when
i was going around the country in iowa
new hampshire and ohio and everywhere
else
they were very passionate about this
because they they lost their paper and
you kind of lose your identity if you
don't have a local paper
so step one is to say look local
journalism or journalism generally
is a public good in a functioning
democracy and we need a way to
to pay for it that is not advertising or
subscription yes
and so why don't you take an andrew yang
like idea um
you know you could imagine giving people
uh
journalism dollars that they could use
to fund their local
local papers um i i completely agree
with you and you know one thing we
forget
is that at the birth of this nation the
biggest expenditures the government made
were expenditures designed to knit
together an infrastructure
of information the post office was the
forefront of that i mean now
we're trying to starve the post office
to defeat uh the election but
at that time the post office was the
biggest employer and and the biggest
debate was whether they should make
newspapers
free to distribute or charge them a tiny
little amount
to filter out you know just junk but
their commitment to subsidize the
production
of news and information and the spread
of information was absolute
and they realized you couldn't have a
nation if you didn't have an
infrastructure of informed citizens i
mean jefferson's idea here is really
powerful and supportive
and what we've done is we've evolved
into a nation where
you know we've handed over the
production of information to these
platforms
whose incentives have nothing to do with
informing us
in a balanced and meaningful way their
incentives are to sell ads the opposite
unfortunately yeah
yeah and until we change those
incentives until that business model has
changed
um i don't know what we do now there are
alternatives i mean this
this right here like a a podcast podcast
you know i like to think about the um
you know you know the slow food movement
which basically says like if you just
cook your food there's like this
little media movement yeah it's the slow
democracy movement slow democracy
movement like if we do democracy
in certain places we can do it well and
if we do it in other places we do it
poorly so if you do democracy on twitter
or facebook it's no good because you're
reacting to the kind of politics of hate
and you're being driven by
ad incentives and all of that is bad but
if you do politics
in like podcasts or long-form narrative
or town hall environments then that's
more fixed to us as humans like we have
a chance to reflect and to think and to
hear both sides and to get deep on an
issue and so the question isn't so much
whether we blow up twitter or facebook
the question is how can we channel
more of our political attention into
places where the attention span is
greater than five seconds i mean you
must have hit this all the time
you know ubi is an obvious point
once you understand it but to understand
it takes five minutes at least or maybe
10 minutes
an hour to explain it and how many you
know
i mean you know i'm a professor so i i i
have the opportunity to force people to
listen to me the lecture for an hour
but if you're out there on the campaign
trail and you've got like 30 seconds to
make your pitch
how are you going to explain an idea
like ubi to in a way that people can
understand but
if you could bring them into a place
like this a podcast where they listen
for an hour to a conversation
then ordinary people anybody can come
around to understanding it so the point
is not that you need smart people
you need smart environments it's not
that you need like
phds running government you just need
people placed in a context where they
have an opportunity
to actually understand before you ask
them what they want to do and we could
build
that environment we just have no
incentive to build it right now
i'm a big believer in common sense and
the judgment
of ordinary americans you go to them and
you say hey
if you had a choice between bailing out
wall street or homeowners what should
you choose
you know like virtually every normal
person would have been like
let's keep people in their homes and you
know i think that's a superior judgment
than the one we actually
uh adopted in oh wait no no again and
again and again
yeah so i agree with you that you don't
need
degrees or irritation necessarily you
just need good information and an
environment that's actually
rewarded for providing you information
in a way or judgment or discussion or
argument like in a way that's
uh balanced and reasonable and meant to
provide
you the tools to participate
uh in in your own democracy
so here's the opportunity maybe uh
here's what i figured out
and this is the big plan i'm going to
try and propose uh
is that so all these local papers have
gone out of existence
we believe that we need to bring them
back i believe or support the ones that
are hanging on and so what you said
about journalism dollars is right
is where i'm going um but the way that
we consume information now is so
uh varied that my thought would be that
it would essentially be a micropayment
model tied to our attention
so let's imagine that every u.s citizen
had
uh fifty dollars a month that goes to
the stuff that they pay attention to
and so then there's and you know you
can't make it complicated for
people so it's essentially just tied to
whatever uh
article i look at or if if i subscribe
to something you know i can use some of
it on that
um and then we could end up creating
like a positive set of supports for some
of the journalism that we want
without having to go down this road of
like you can't say this you can't say
that in other words you reward the
positive
uh without trying to circumscribe
communication in other sectors and you
make it so that like the
the unreasonable media is
more clearly such as shall we say like
if you've got like the carnival barker
on the side
uh you know yelling about things then
you can be like look you can yell like
you know
it's you're right it's just you're not
going to participate in this
uh in this journalism dollars uh set of
uh incentives and rewards well so is
journalism dollars
directed to just the bottom line or is
it directed to certain kind of
activities
that we know we can't do anymore i mean
like the most important activity
journalism
used to do was investigative journalism
i mean
the only way to keep local governments
honest was for a reporter to show up at
city hall meetings
um or to you know go to city hall and
talk to people and now there are no
reporters anymore so the corruption at
the local level is exploding
um so is journalism dollars driven
towards uh
like supporting particular kinds of
journalism or it's just we're gonna give
you money based on the number of
eyeballs that you happen to attract
so the initial thought and part of the
reason why i liked
the um i like being
paid based on your attention is i'm also
concerned that we have a creative
atmosphere that is
increasingly impossible for musicians
artists
uh of all kinds
as well as journalists but i agree with
you that there's some fundamental
public purpose to journalism one of the
things i suggested on the campaign trail
was
that we publicly fund a number of
investigative journalists per
congressional district
with the thinking being like you know
what if you you have a congressional
district i'm sure there's important
stuff going on there and so you have
these journalism fellows
that uh you have a great idea and we had
it it's like the same number as like
congressman you get
it's federally funded they're there like
you would probably knight someone from
within the community it'd be like this
big honor
um we essentially have to make
journalism this uh publicly valued
profession
and i got into this giant not not giant
it was like a minor twitter spat
oh this issue where i was like look
uh journalism's dying and we need a new
model to fix it
and then some journalists uh took issue
with me and said you know
journalism is adapting and work updating
is a new thing and then i just went on
this
mini diatribe i was like look 1000 plus
local papers out of existence i've been
to those towns people
are uh are devastated by their loss
every journalism every journalist knows
hundreds or thousands of colleagues
who've lost their jobs
over this last period of time if a young
person comes to you and asks
about going into the field you try and
scare them off
you're like this is not the field you
want you want to
to go into you have major media outlets
like time magazine
um or not time yeah time
uh being bought by media moguls oh no
sorry tech moguls as like a trophy
property
you know washington post you know like
bought by bezos
uh and so we we have this market
distortion of journalism
that is going to make in my opinion a
functional democracy impossible to
resuscitate or rejuvenate well i i think
it's a really important idea for
creativity in general this my i don't
know if you know of
my colleague terry fisher who wrote this
really wonderful book called promises to
keep about copyright
and his idea for copyright was you know
copyright used to be obsessed with
controlling copies
in the digital age that makes no sense
instead what we ought to do is just make
it
totally trivially easy for people to
copy things all over the place
but then artists get paid based on the
frequency with which their content gets
consumed
so you know if you happen to be an
incredibly popular artist like we're
tracking who's consuming what and you
get paid based on the fact that
people want to listen to you ten times
more than yeah i'll love it i never
understand that but that just seems to
be the reality of music so
so that's a way of like encouraging
people to create and encouraging the
sharing of creativity
but also guaranteeing that artists get
paid and i think that would work for a
good chunk of the journalism part but i
do think that
the other idea you were talking about is
really critical you need journalists
who in some sense are not thinking about
the bottom line yeah
the great thing the new york times can
do is they can say to a investigative
journalist like take a year
just think about this for a year and at
the end of it if we've got something we
got something if we don't we don't but
i'm not gonna your job is not gonna hang
on whether you get a pulitzer prize
winning uh article at the end
and so i think these fellowships is a
really great idea like pro publica
supports the idea of basically creating
effectively fellowships in journalism
we could multiply that i love the
congressional district because you want
to really drive it into the local
jurisdictions and say like there are 10
journalist fellow you know
republican fellows in every district um
and then
let these people you know be judged
locally about whether they're doing good
work
but at least you'd begin to drive
attention to an area which right now
there's no return for like why why would
you ever talk about it
yeah so there are so many things we we
need to do in the media
sector in particular it's funny and you
you were ahead of me on this as well
uh you know your last book talked about
a lot of these issues i kind of lived it
i lived my version
of it yeah but i'm convinced
uh changing the incentives for media has
to be part of the
the puzzle or part of the process
because at this point people are getting
their information
in very limited ways and when you talk
about podcasts too this is
like a thing that i'm very sensitive to
it's like podcasts work for folks like
you and i that have a following
um but it's it's not like a real
replacement
like do i love podcasts yes i do uh you
know obviously
[Laughter]
we're on it um and that was one of the
things that some folks in the media came
back to me about
where they said like look like we have
these podcasts
and i said well you have that podcast
because you're a big deal journalist and
you actually can get audience but it's
not like the
the format does not replace
other forms of journalism it certainly
doesn't replace the investigative
journalism you're talking about
yeah i i don't think it replaces it all
i'm trying to think about is
like how do we get people yeah how do we
get people into the right context
for the kind of question we want them to
think about i mean this is
i think what's interesting here is i
just think this is a sort of problem we
never had to worry about before like
serious problems were in context where
you had serious attention to think about
it you had time to think about it
and now we've got to make sure that's
possible instead of like imagining
people are going to make a judgment
about who the democratic nominee is
going to be
based on their twitter feed or their
facebook news feed
like how do we get them into a place
where they have a better opportunity
to think about the range of people so
you know you experience new hampshire
an extraordinary context where
people meet people face to face over the
course of two years by the end of that
two-year period everybody knew who
andrew yang was everybody
knew your character they didn't know you
threw your ads on i don't know if you
had television ads but they didn't know
you through
ads yeah we spent approximately
i think it was something like uh four or
five million on uh
in new hampshire alone that's great but
that's not how they do new hampshire
but not just because of that the point
is they could see you face to face and
know your character i mean i remember
that town hall
where uh you know you appeal to our
children and like what are we leaving
our children and you
your eyes welled up and i looked out in
the audience and people were weeping
that was that was because new hampshire
puts
politics at a personal retail level
and so people have a deep understanding
of the character because of the place
that they begin to meet them and we got
to think that way about these problems
generally like
you know it's okay to think about what
brand of toothpaste you need to be
consuming at the kind of twitter level
attention span like you don't need to
worry about that so much but who the
next president should be
or like whether ubi should be at the
center of any economic plan
that takes real thought not not smart
thought it just takes as you were saying
common sense thought but common sense
driven by people who have an opportunity
to understand both sides
and to reflect on it in a way that gives
them confidence
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]